[Musique]
cette envie aujourd'hui c'est vous
François Germaine bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'être là
vous êtes membre du GIEC donc vous avez
co-écrit le dernier rapport vous publiez
ces jours-ci l'écologie n'est pas un
consensus dépassé l'indignation qui est
sorti chez fire on va en reparler dans
un instant et vous serez la semaine
prochaine à Charmel cher pour la COP 27
une coop François Germaine ou les
interventions de ce genre se multiplient
est sticking leur tourne nous nous
battons pour nos vies et nous sommes en
train de perdre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre continue
les températures dans le monde
augmentent et notre planète approche du
point de bascule qui rendra le chaos
climatique irréversible nous sommes sur
une autoroute en direction d'un climat
de l'enfer avec notre pied qui reste sur
l'accélérateur
nous sommes sur une autoroute en
direction d'un climat de l'enfer avec
notre pied qui reste sur l'accélérateur
d'Ille patron de l'ONU est-ce que vous
diriez que cette Cope François Jemen
constitue un tournant plus qu'une autre
car nous avons tous quasiment partout
dans le monde individuellement fait
d'expérience ces derniers mois de la
réalité voire de l'accélération du
dérèglement climatique très clairement
un élément nouveau pour cette coque peut
effectivement que les pays
industrialisés ont pris conscience ces
dernières années qu'ils étaient eux
aussi vulnérables aux impacts du
changement climatique et que donc il
était aussi dans leur intérêt à eux de
lutter contre le changement climatique
peut-être qu'avant les pays
industrialisés voyez la lutte contre le
changement climatique davantage comme
une forme d'aide au pays du Sud là il se
rend compte qu'ils sont touchés
également la grande difficulté
évidemment ça va être de voir comment
nous allons pouvoir progresser malgré
les tensions internationales qui sont
nombreuses il y a évidemment la guerre
d'Ukraine il y a la Chine et les
États-Unis qui ne se parlent plus de
climat depuis la visite de Nancy Pelosi
à Taïwan et puis elle énergétique qui
pousse une politique de Sauve qui peut
chez beaucoup de pays au point que
certains doivent même rouvrir des mines
de charbon donc ces trois éléments assez
compliqués pour avancer est-ce que
l'impression que le dérèglement ou le
réchauffement climatique s'accélère et
juste est-ce qu'il s'accélère
véritablement et si oui pourquoi il
s'accélère et il va continuer à
s'accélérer au point même que parfois
que certains modèles n'avaient pas prévu
une telle accélération et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde tous les indicateurs
que ce soit à la fois pour la hausse de
la température mais aussi pour la hausse
du niveau des mers par exemple on voit
que ce sont des phénomènes qui
s'accélèrent et très clairement on est
entré dans un mouvement irréversible et
il faut se rendre compte que aujourd'hui
tout ce que nous pouvons faire c'est
essayer de limiter au maximum la hausse
des températures qui aura pas de retour
en arrière donc l'enjeu n'est plus
depuis longtemps de stopper le
réchauffement de la planète mais de
contenir l'ampleur du réchauffement
est-ce que on est vraiment face à un
problème graduel plutôt que face à un
problème binaire ça c'est très important
parce que beaucoup dans l'opinion
publique pense encore que c'est pile ou
face gagné ou perdu non on en est plus
là aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de limiter
au maximum est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer vous dites que un dixième
d'augmentation de degrés change
énormément de choses alors que peut-être
le ressenti qu'on peut avoir n'est pas
celui-là on se dit 1 2 degrés de plus
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer pour nous
au fond est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'en fait ça
change beaucoup de choses ça change
beaucoup de choses et c'est vrai et je
comprends les gens qui vivent finalement
un ou deux degrés est-ce que ça fait
vraiment une grosse différence il faut
toujours garder en tête que c'est des
élévations de température par rapport à
la température moyenne la température
moyenne annuelle en France c'est 14
degrés donc ça veut dire que si on prend
deux trois ou quatre degrés en France ça
fait des augmentations de l'ordre de 20
ou 25% de température et très clairement
chaque dixième de degré notamment par
rapport à la hausse du niveau des mers
ou par rapport à la multiplication des
catastrophes climatiques va provoquer
une énorme différence énorme dégâts et
d'énormes souffrances supplémentaires à
travers le monde et donc il faut
vraiment se battre pour chaque dixième
de degré et ça veut dire que chaque
tonne de CO2 va faire une énorme
différence et qu'il n'y a absolument
aucune action qui soit inutile contre le
changement climatique donc l'engagement
historique pris à Paris en 2015
c'est-à-dire limiter à 1 et demi degrés
le réchauffement climatique par rapport
à l'air pré-industriel ça on le sait ce
n'est pas tenable donc quel est
l'objectif tenable aujourd'hui
l'objectif tenable aujourd'hui et je
crois qu'il faut se refocaliser sur cet
objectif c'est deux degrés très
clairement c'était l'objectif central de
l'accord de Paris l'accord de Paris
avait ajouté un degré et demi si
possible et en fait c'était surtout une
concession faite aux représentants des
petits États insulaires mais en réalité
dès l'accord de Paris on savait que
c'était pas tenable simplement parce que
quoi qu'il arrive nous serons à un degré
et demi d'augmentation de température
vers 2035 François Germaine on entend
dire à charmer le Cher qu'il faut passer
à la vitesse supérieure mais quand on
sait que les coques précéd non pas les
objectifs non pas été tenus par aucun
des participants que la France par
exemple on entend d'Emmanuel Macron hier
a été déjà condamné deux fois pour une
action climatique comment est-ce qu'on
peut dépasser le décalage d'aucun dirait
l'hypocrisie entre ces injonctions à
passer à l'étape supérieure et la
réalité des faits effectivement on a
l'impression d'un décalage entre le
changement climatique qui accélère sur
le terrain qui est au galop et des
négociations internationales qui se
traînent qui avancent péniblement si ces
négociations avancent aussi lentement je
crois que c'est notamment parce qu'elles
sont bridées par la règle du consensus
il n'y a pas de vote dans les coques
toutes les décisions doivent se prendre
à l'unanimité des participants et
évidemment des pays qui ont intérêt à ce
que les choses avancent le plus
lentement possible l’arabie Saoudite par
exemple ou les États-Unis quand Donald
Trump était président et donc tant qu'on
sera par cette règle du consensus
on sera condamné être déçu en permanence
du résultat des coques si vous êtes un
minimum ambitieux sur le climat mais
vous pouvez jamais être satisfait et
donc je crois que une voix d'avenir pour
aller plus vite c'est de s'affranchir de
cette règle du consensus et de permettre
à des coalitions de pays d'avancer plus
rapidement sur certains sujets on a déjà
vu cette préfiguration l'an dernier à
Glasgow est-ce que ça ne veut pas dire
aussi qu'elle au stade où on en est le
virage ne peut plus être amorcé que par
d'autres d'autres personnes ou d'autres
individus que les dirigeants politiques
ça pose la question du saisissement
sociétal de ces questions absolument je
pense qu'on a tendance à trop attendre
des gouvernements ou à trop attendre des
cops et attendre certainement plus que
ce qu'elles ne peuvent donner les cops
c'est juste un forum de discussion entre
États les cops n'ont pas le pouvoir
d'imposer quoi que ce soit elles n'ont
pas de fonction performatives même la
Coop la plus réussie du monde ne peut
pas à elle seule sauver le climat et
donc je crois aujourd'hui qu'on a bien
davantage intérêt à encourager les
actions qui se font déjà au sein des
entreprises des collectivités ou de la
société civile et essaie de les
amplifier pour véritablement une
fonction d'émulation qu'elles entraînent
la majorité à leur sujet pendant
quelques années pendant plusieurs années
on faisait l'éloge des petits pas des
petits pas les uns après les autres qui
à la fin faisait un grand tour on a
l'impression qu'on a dépassé ça et ça ça
pose la question de la façon dont les
sociétés s'emparent aujourd'hui de ces
sujets et celle de la radicalité je mets
des guillemets dans les questions dans
votre livre des manifestations musclées
à la soupe lancée sur les tableaux de
maître est-ce que ça c'est
utile est-ce que c'est légitime est-ce
que ça permet de parler du sujet dont
globalement ça fait du bien ou est-ce
que ça ne sert à rien c'est un peu comme
si on était passé d'un extrême à l'autre
et j'ai envie de dire on a on s'est
longtemps concentré sur les actions
individuelles les petits pas qui sont
certes importants mais qui ne sont pas
suffisants et puis on est passé en
disant c'est les gouvernements c'est la
négociation internationale qui doit tout
résoudre comme si c'est une façon aussi
d'absoudre la société de changer j'ai
tendance à croire que la solution est
peut-être entre les deux dans les corps
intermédiaires au niveau des
collectivités et des entreprises qui
peuvent véritablement actionner
d'importants leviers de et qui peuvent
entraîner à leur suite tout en
écosystème de citoyen d'autres acteurs
et ça ça me paraît très important parce
que ce qui motive aujourd'hui les
actions plus radicales des activistes
c'est l'impression que rien ne change
que rien n'est fait qu'aucune alerte ne
t'entendue mais je pense que c'est un
message qui est aussi assez démobilisant
en fait parce que moi je vois et vous 6
sans doute je vois beaucoup de choses
qui changent au sein de la société il me
semble aujourd'hui qu'on a davantage
intérêt à encourager ce qui est en train
de changer ceux qui sont en train de
faire bouger les choses plutôt qu'à sans
cesse désolé que rien ne bouge parce
qu'à la fin ça finit par être
performatif sauf qu'allons sauf que
l'enjeu si on essaie de réfléchir de
façon globale c'est comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire cause commune aujourd'hui
entre un indien un soudané un Américain
un Français exemple on dit aux Français
de réduire leur consommation de viande
en Chine en même temps on ouvre des
fermes porcines de 26 étages avec je ne
sais combien de dizaines de milliers de
bêtes à l'intérieur qu'est-ce que quel
est le message que l'on peut comprendre
de pour ça et comment on peut répondre à
ce qui paraît un paradoxal et on peut se
décourager et on peut avoir mille une
raison de se décourager en se disant
mais à quoi est-ce que ça sert que moi
je fasse des efforts à quoi est-ce que
ça sert que la France fasse des efforts
sinon du côté la Chine ouvre ses énormes
ferme-porting 2130 à charbon par seconde
si le PSG fait Paris Nantes en jet privé
ça c'est parce qu'on voit les choses de
façon binaire en réalité il faut
réaliser que vraiment il y a aucune
action
inutile et donc c'est pas parce que la
Chine fait ceci ou que le PSG fait cela
que nos actions deviennent insuffisantes
au contraire nos actions deviennent
davantage importantes encore précisément
parce que les autres font cela mais
aussi il faut absolument que notre
action sur le changement climatique
dépasse nos propres frontières c'est à
dire qu'on doit pas se tracasser
uniquement de nos émissions mais voir
comment on peut travailler avec les
autres pays pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre l'action
climatique nous condamne en quelque
sorte à agir au-delà de nos frontières
que ses frontières soit géographiques ou
générationnelle on définit une espèce de
le bon comportement je me savais que des
guillemets écologiquement correct disons
standard quand on connaît les disparités
de la planète sociale culturelle
géographique voilà bien sûr il faut il
faut admettre aussi que une des raisons
pour laquelle nous devons nous diminuer
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est pour que ces émissions puissent
augmenter dans certains pays parce que
dans certains pays il y a des logiques
de développement pour sortir les gens de
la pauvreté qui vont conduire à une
augmentation des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et donc il faut
absolument que nous revenions à cette
approche cosmopolitique qui dépasse
absolument les nationalismes je dis
souvent que le pire ennemi du climat ce
ne sont pas les énergies fossiles ce
sont les nationalismes et ça pose aussi
la question en quelques mots que vous
posez dans votre livre pourquoi
l'écologie politique peine à percer
quand clairement elle ces questions
climatiques sont un vrai sujet de
préoccupation dans les sociétés vous
dites notamment que c'est parce que
cette écologie politique ne sait pas
être cosmopolitique tout à fait et que
nous avons beaucoup du mal à agir pour
les autres nous avons tendance à agir
pour nous-mêmes et l'altruisme
malheureusement c'est pas le domaine
dans lequel on excelle et donc c'est
aussi quelque part une question
profondément morale est-ce que nous
sommes capables de dépasser nos propres
frontières nos propres intérêts c'est
une vaste question c'est une des
questions qui est au centre de ce livre
la question de l'habitabilité de la
terre est universalisme dites-vous merci
beaucoup Françoise
n'est pas un
constellindignation à lire chez Fayard
merci encore on se retrouve juste après
la pause avec Damien coquet